and the human beings who inhabited the
realm of midgard needed to make sure the
gods were happy in order to keep the
order and so that they could be
protected
for this reason humans performed various
rights such as offerings sacrifices and
other cultic practices as a form of
worship and exchange
in turn the gods had to protect
themselves as well as human beings
sometimes from the inhabitants of utgaud
sometimes jotenheim which included the
arch enemies of the Gods the yotan or
Giants we will dive deeper into the
actual cosmology and mythology of this
system later on but this is the general
outline one that of course reminds us a
lot about other polytheistic religions
from different parts of the world
foreign
[Music]